um thank you for coming i'm glad i've
got some faces in here i know i'm
competing with steve sanderson and john
skeet so anyone in this room is good and
hopefully some people online as well
my name's steve i'm a microsoft mvp
pluralsight author and engineer at
elastic i work on the language clients
team at elastic
and that might give you a clue as to why
i've chosen this title for this session
a little bit about the title just to
make sure everyone's expectations are
correct this is an introductory level
talk so if you've used elasticsearch
much uh you probably know a lot or some
of this stuff
but
hopefully it will also be a good recap
of some technology that you've already
heard about and then we'll move more
towards the latter half of the session
to talk about uh the net client and
working with elasticsearch.net so um
so that's that's kind of the plan but if
it is too introductory for you i won't
be offended if you decide to kind of
find somewhere else to go
um the other important thing is there is
a bitly link there um everyone wants to
slide after the session i've got like a
resources link at the end in the slides
that link takes you to the slide deck so
grab that link and you'll have access to
all of the resources and all of the
information that i'm going to cover in
the session today
um it's a
three-day conference so if you have any
questions that you don't get answered in
this session or after this session come
and find me over any of the three days
at the event i'll be happy to
talk about elasticsearch and the.net
client with you
um i'm very keen for that but if you if
you think of something later
you can reach out to me i'm on twitter
steve j gordon
and you can follow my blog as well where
i hope to kind of get that going again
with more posts about uh elasticsearch
and using the.net client
so with that let's dive straight in i'm
not a marketing person but i do have a
marketing looking slide that i stole out
of our corporate slide deck um but it's
a good intro to who we are as a company
so
you know how many people in this room
have actually heard of elastic already
most nearly everyone that's good it
means my work here is really easy you
probably know then that you know we
primarily do stuff around search that's
what people know us for
we build search solutions on top of a
single stack so what does that mean well
we have the course stack that i'm going
to introduce to you in a moment but we
also use that stack ourselves to develop
products and solutions that you can use
for search-based activities within your
organizations as well so one of those is
enterprise search enterprise search
gives you various capabilities one of
the things you could do is point at a
website or an application and have it
crawl that site gather data that you can
then expose through a search box on that
website so it might be good if you're
running a blog for example you could
point
elasticsearch at that
you can also use it for sorting and
searching data within your organization
so everyone has huge disparate amounts
of data now we have stuff in github we
have stuff over in a wiki we have stuff
on google docs and slack and finding
that information knowing where to look
for the answer to a question you might
have internally can always be tough
enterprise search allows you to call all
of those sources for that information
index it and make it searchable in your
organization and we use that internally
and it proves really useful i'm tracking
stuff down and i find someone slacked a
message about that in the past and i get
the answer that i'm looking for
we also do stuff around observability
everyone is sort of building more and
more sort of distributed systems
cloud-based solutions and services
observability is really important in
those scenarios to understand how things
are working if they're working and if
they're working normally and we have
various products and technologies within
that solution space for observability uh
so we have apm that you can install into
various platforms to gather data about
your applications how they're running uh
we also have the capability to expose
that to you in dashboards through kibana
and build alerting and tooling around
that and you can even combine that with
our ml technologies to start having
alerts that are a bit more intelligent
and are actually looking for true
outliers in your data rather than just
fixed levels that may or may not alert
incorrectly for you
and then finally we have some stuff
around security again security is
another big topic in organizations how
do we secure our environments how do we
understand if they're secure and where
are the risks our security solutions can
uh detect threats within your
organization detect those potential uh
attacks that may be happening and help
you mitigate against them so that's some
of the stuff we do you can check out our
website for a lot more information on
all of that
today i'm going to be focused on one
small part of our stack really which is
elasticsearch but it is the heart of the
stack pretty much everything links into
elasticsearch in some way or another
it's the data store fundamentally where
all of your data is going to get stored
it's going to be indexed and it's going
to be made searchable so this is where
we're going to do all of the search and
allow analysis of our data
and elasticsearch is kind of where the
company began but we've evolved over the
last sort of number of years to build
out much bigger
stack that makes it a lot easier to
utilize elasticsearch for the things you
may be building and one of the tools
that we have is kibana this is our ui
layer
this gives you the capability to not
only manage your elastic search cluster
so actually do you know your
configuration setting up users that kind
of operational type management but it
also gives you the ability to visualize
the data that's stored in those clusters
and so you can build dashboards you can
build reporting tools for internal or
external customers that you may need to
be able to show people to see how things
are operating in your business we used
it quite extensively in my old job just
as part of our sort of platform
monitoring system that we were able to
sort of see how all of our services were
performing and if any of the servers
looked like they were getting unexpected
loads that kind of thing
we also need to get data into
elasticsearch and elasticsearch has an
api and we'll be talking more about
using the.net client to interact with
that api in a bit but sometimes you know
you have common data sources within your
organization that you want to use
as as sources for data that's going into
elasticsearch and we have a number of
products as part of our stack that help
you with that the most recent i guess of
those is elastic agent and it's
typically the one you should sort of
start looking at first where you can
install this agent on servers services
and and various devices around your
organization and connect it into our
fleet server so that you can then start
managing your fleet of
servers in terms of how you want to
collect data from them so you can set up
profiles to gather various log data or
metric data off those systems
before agent we had beats which is a
very similar concept but you needed to
install specific beats on each server
instance where you needed to collect
certain types of data maybe metrics or
audit data each of these was an
independent installation
elastic agent makes that easier by kind
of essentially giving you a central
management point for doing all of that
configuration
and then finally we have logsdash which
is as the name may suggest about log
data
typically with this you would point at a
directory that contains or will contain
some log data and have it scrape that
data
parse it process it and store it into
elasticsearch for you so we have a
number of those kind of pipelines for
common log file formats today
but it's also extremely extensible and
configurable if you want to build your
own pipelines for your own specific log
data you can determine how that data
gets processed split apart which pieces
of that information you care about
storing
do some kind of enrichment so if you've
got ip data in there you may do gip
lookups as part of your ingestion
pipeline
and then bringing that all into
elasticsearch
so this is the kind of core stack this
is what our solutions are built on top
of and what you can build your solutions
on top of as well
in terms of where you can and how you
can run this
today the best choice if you're kind of
getting started and you're new to this
will be usually elastic cloud this is
our software as a service offering and
it gives you the ability to spin up a
deployment of elasticsearch you know at
the few clicks of a button
and it gives you the ability to manage
that deployment with very little sort of
overhead really we do all of the hard
work of making sure everything's spun up
and configured correctly and secured and
talking to one another and you can
really focus on how much data do i need
to store what sort of scale am i looking
to start with and and then just getting
started with it
i use it quite often just for
prototyping things um you know just
testing out ideas testing out things i'm
going to be able to put into the client
that kind of thing
and it's a really good way of doing that
with as i say very little overhead
we also have on-prem
you may be in an organization that can't
or doesn't want to use cloud
that's fine we have on-prem offerings
for that we can offer elastic cloud
enterprise which is essentially the
elastic cloud ui and management plane
but in your own environment which is
quite nice it means you get sort of the
best of both worlds if you're in that
situation where you're not allowed to
put data into the cloud
you can use that similarly if you're in
a sort of containerized environment and
heavy into sort of kubernetes and things
you can get started with elastic cloud
and kubernetes as well
the final option which is the kind of i
want to do everything myself mode is
standalone and you're now fully
responsible for installing your elastic
search instances onto servers or vms or
however you want to get those up and
running maybe even docker
but you're then responsible for making
sure that stuff works works reliably and
is configured correctly to be secure and
all of that kind of stuff so it's it's
kind of the option you probably don't
want to go to first today because you
know there's a lot of things you have to
think about and by going towards the
cloud end of this most of it is just
sliders and choices around scaling that
you need to deal with
it's also important to mention as well i
miss miss saying that elastic cloud is
available in all of the major cloud
providers so
while you access it through our cloud
sort of platform you can determine where
your deployments exist it might be azure
google cloud aws
means you can put your you know your
data services near where the rest of
your application stuff may be running in
a cloud already
so let's start with you know the real
intro to elasticsearch and some of the
basic um terminology and we'll sort of
start to ramp up into the deeper layers
of this as we go
so the first term i've used it a few
times already is cluster
a cluster is really simply a collection
of servers or really elastic search
instances is the thing to think about so
the cluster is the way you group the
logically
your sort of data environment together
and through that all of your data is
stored and all of the federated indexing
and searching capabilities happen
so it's really more of a logical concept
there are some configuration options
that you will configure that would be
cluster-wide but mostly it's about
choosing a cluster name that you want
your servers to join into and start
working as a distributed data store
in terms of
how that looks we have nodes and those
are really just an instance of elastic
search so it might be a physical server
it might be a vm
could be a container
ultimately it is just that installation
of elasticsearch that's going to be
working together with the other nodes
within the system
to be able to provide the services that
you need from elasticsearch
and how you set this up um depends on
your needs within your organization you
can run a one node cluster uh don't do
it in production
but you can do it when you're developing
just to kind of get started and
experiment with things often in cloud
i'll you know spin up just a single node
thinking the cloud i'm going to use one
today for the later demos so
you can do that just to get started you
don't need to have the full capacity but
obviously as your system moves towards
production you need to start thinking
about how's this thing going to scale
how is it going to be
resilient to faults and that kind of
thing and so a minimum of three nodes is
kind of where you want to get to as a an
entry-level
cluster
when i worked for my previous company we
had what i thought at the time was quite
a big cluster we had about 35 nodes and
we were quite impressed that we had
terabytes of data and 7 million
documents a day since joining alaska
i've learned that we were barely
touching the the tip of the iceberg in
terms of pure scale of this thing
there's people running you know hundreds
hundreds maybe thousands of nodes
together to get
really large volumes of data indexed and
searched
in their environments the main thing
about the nodes is by default they
configured they are configured to kind
of start up in essentially multi
a multi-role situation they'll do pretty
much anything as part of their operation
within the cluster but as you
as you move towards production and you
get a feel for what your cluster's
actually needing to do in terms of
operations that you'll have will be
happening you may start to determine
specific roles for specific nodes and
also start splitting those roles against
more appropriate hardware types for
those roles so for example data nodes
will need a lot of disk capacity to
store the physical data that's part of
the index that you're storing there and
they generally need quite a good amount
of memory uh high performance memory for
the in-memory data structures that are
needed to provide the search
capabilities very quickly
other nodes that are about sort of
maintaining the cluster state and
maintaining how the clusters operating
are called master nodes and you really
only need
basic machines as master eligible nodes
so typically once you get past a certain
size you'll start to have dedicated
masternodes that are purely about
keeping the cluster alive and not about
storing data or performing search or
index capabilities similarly if you want
to use our machine learning technologies
within the cluster
we typically would expect you to have
machine learning dedicated nodes
just for performing those functions and
they may have higher cpu loads
again higher memory loads so you might
want to choose appropriate hardware for
those types of jobs this isn't something
you have to determine right up front you
can start with this kind of a free node
cluster with all the roles and then as
you kind of understand the data you're
dealing with and understand your
environment that's when you start adding
nodes to the cluster and giving them
different roles just through
configuration
then we have the concept of an index
index is one of those terms that's kind
of a bit overloaded it's a noun it's a
verb but in this case it's the noun the
object which is really just a collection
of documents
logically within your your data store
and often questions come in from like
how how should i determine what should
go into what index and and what's my
strategy and the answer is it really
does depend on your data
if you are for example running a blog
website and you just want to provide a
search capability across that then you
can have a single index that contains
all of the blog posts as data objects
that you want to be able to search
across and that's relatively finite data
even on a large blog we're talking
thousands of documents probably at most
but sometimes we have data that isn't
really finite as such so log data would
be a great example this data is going to
be continually coming in from
applications and servers over time and
typically what you do in that scenario
is you start to move towards a strategy
where you have indexes
created in in sort of buckets so you
might have weekly indexes
for storing that data as time goes on
and you'll notice i always forget to be
it's like indices and indexes it doesn't
really matter
i use both
but you can spread that data across
as time goes on so typically by doing
that it gives you more capability for
determining how that data is backed up
and also how you store it
maybe on colder less
high-powered hardware over time because
typically index data you want to be able
to search over the immediate last maybe
few days of data very quickly but most
of your year old data may be needed
needed for sort of regulatory reasons or
auditing reasons but you typically
aren't doing hot searches across that
data all the time and so you can have
strategies where through our index life
cycle management policies you can
configure data to move through a life
cycle where it goes on to older and
older nodes which are basically cheaper
hardware for you to the point where you
can even have data stored in blob stores
as searchable snapshots where you can
actually search across it it's going to
be slower but it's going to be a lot
cheaper and so you can start to think
about these strategies as time goes on i
won't be talking about them today but
most of that's done for a technology
called data streams where you configure
a stream of data and it handles
configuring a policy behind the scenes
for you that will roll that data over to
indexes over time
within an index we have
shards and chart is just you know common
term in distributed databases how are we
going to separate this data so that we
can spread the load
across multiple systems and so in this
case let's take this example at the
moment where this first index of hours
we've configured with a single primary
shard so there are a few problems with
this there are a few things we need to
think about as engineers
but the first thing is imagine this is
our main index that we this is why we
have a cluster we've got three nodes and
we've set it up but we're only creating
a single shard of our data so this means
all of the data for that index lives on
node one it also means all of the search
and the index load is on node one uh
it's not a great use of the the other
two nodes in our cluster which are
essentially sitting there uh doing
nothing
so one of the things we need to think
about when we design how we're going to
create our indexes
in the system
is how do we want to shard that data and
there's no fixed answer on this some of
this is documented on our blog posts and
our documentation that gives you some
guidance but it really depends on your
data loads how much ingestion will you
have how much search will you have how
much overall data have you got
as to what's the right number of shards
for your system and sometimes it is a
case of trying different things again in
my old job we started with a strategy i
think where we were on three charts for
our each
index and after time we realized if we
split that out into i think six
jars we got better throughput overall
and it was a kind of right balance
because there is a cost associated with
sharding your data there's a management
overhead and search may have to you know
split uh consolidate its data again
afterwards so what we typically
recommend is you have more than one
primary shard for your data and it's
split across um some of your nodes you
don't really care which nodes the
cluster and elasticsearch will configure
itself to put shards for the best load
balancing across the system
but in this case now we're in a
situation where our data is now spread
across the free nodes and this is done
by just hashing the id essentially of
the documents as they come in and then
that data lives on a particular node
and it means that when we do a search
now across the entire index that search
can be sent to each of the nodes each of
them is collecting and gathering the
data that's the matches for that search
and then it gets consolidated back
together again at the end
now this situation is better from a
point of view of getting a better load
across our system
we still have a resiliency issue here in
this design and we can resolve that by
having replicas so as well as
configuring the number of primaries we
want we can configure the number of
replicas that we want as well in this
case we said we want one replica which
means we want one replica of each
primary hence we have three actual
shards there that are showing up and the
key thing here is that elasticsearch is
obviously going to try and put this in a
sensible configuration that means that
we have resiliency so now nodes one node
one has primary one and replica one is
on node two and this means that we could
lose node one entirely
and we'd be still in a situation where
we can perform search initially and as
soon as the cluster detects that the
health is no longer in a good state it
can't reach node one and it needs to
figure out well what primaries node one
and how do i promote the replicas so
that we can get back to a state where
everything's healthy and we're able to
take data back in and index it again
so this configuration is important to
think about as you move towards
production
you will want at least one replica and
you also want to think about your backup
strategy through snapshots as well but
that's sort of a bit past what we're
going to get into today
the final piece of basic terminology is
a document and a document is a unit of
data really
elasticsearch is a json-based document
store so you send a json object into the
database that represents the data you
want to have indexed in there
and that that actual source document
will be stored by default as part of the
record within elasticsearch
elasticsearch
documents needs generally to have some
related characteristics to make sense
putting them in the same index but each
index is schemeless by design and so you
can send it any data that you want any
structure and we will try and store it
in that index but as i say if you're
going to be doing search across it some
of those fields will need to be common
in some way for it to make sense for you
to put that together but it does mean
that you can evolve your data over time
which is something that very much
happens in businesses as they build out
applications as they understand their
needs they start to add different fields
to the data that they're starting to
store and over time that data might
become more useful for the business
going forward
so i said there's no set schema
but we do have a concept called mapping
and mapping is about determining and
guiding elastic search in how it
actually stores the data into its
various index data structures which is
how we're going to provide the search
capability that you want so to kind of
explain that a little bit more
if your json document comes in and it
has something that looks like a text
field on there
the good chance is that's going to be
text data that you want to be able to
search across but before elasticsearch
determines that it might do a little bit
of parsing and go well does this thing
actually conform to a known date time
string if it does then if it looks like
a date we'll treat it as a date and this
happens the first time a field is seen
new field is seen for any document
elasticsearch will infer by default um
a sort of an implicit mapping for that
field unless you've given it any other
information
so other types of mappings that you'll
see is if it sees something that looks
like a number then it will choose one of
the number field types to use for that
and this is where you have to get a
little careful though this sort of
implied mapping is fine but it it will
make the best judgment based on the
first bit of data it sees so we'll see
that a little bit in the demo when i
talk about how i've chosen the mappings
for that demo scenario but other things
that you're having there is obviously
text this is going to be a key part of
your search capability and one of the
reasons a lot of people will go to
elasticsearch is for some form of full
text search capability in their in their
environment
search is an interesting thing across
text because we actually index that data
in two ways by default we store it into
what's called a text field
which is what provides the full text
search capability so this is where the
data is actually analyzed and tokenized
so that the individual terms can be sort
of read from that and then used to store
in the inverted index that's used for
that very quick lookup between terms and
the documents that contain them
so this process does a number of things
as part of that sort of analysis and
tokenization
things like punctuation are lost or
removed from there stop words by default
will be removed so and the it's those
kind of words are not going to be really
useful in any kind of search so they're
stripped from the documents by default
and typically all of those tokens will
be lowercased as well that means you
know the search full text search is
generally sort of case insensitive by
default this is all configurable you can
configure which filters run for which
fields and how you want to analyze the
data as it comes through
but the default system is is the one
that i've just described
the other way that text data is stored
by default is into what's called a
keyword field type as well and this is
where the data is designed for kind of
exact match scenarios
and so
this is the best guess that
elasticsearch can make if you've not
provided any guidance it will give you
kind of both those options but each of
those indexing structures has some
overhead and it's typically unlikely
that you're going to need both for
all field types so this is where
explicit mapping comes in and you can
start to say for your
index
configuration that you want a particular
mapping for particular fields and say
actually this thing that looks like a
string is actually a version number or
it's an ip address
these types of additional mappings give
us additional capabilities in within
elasticsearch because as soon as we know
a field type is of one of these special
types we can treat it in such a way that
for example with versions we can sort
them for you in simva order rather than
just alphabetical order which may not
always give you the results that you're
expecting
similarly we support things like geodata
so you can provide lat long data and
things like that and then you can
perform geo-based searches over the data
providing a central point and a radius
that you want to search for documents
within or you can set a geo boundary
around the area that you want to search
for and find records that fall into that
zone
so there's lots and lots of field types
and and this is really about
understanding your data most people if
they're kind of
some prototyping something new they'll
start with the inferred mappings and
just take what elasticsearch does out of
the box and as they start to understand
their data both what's coming in and how
people are going to be searching across
it what the use cases are for that data
you might start to adjust your mappings
over time now you can't necessarily
change your mapping in an existing index
you have to do something called
re-indexing you create a new index
structure with a new mapping that
defines exactly how you want this data
to be indexed and then just re-index the
data through to it but this is how
typically people will evolve data in
their businesses
now all of elasticsearch is accessible
through its http interface
and a lot of people will work with it
that way but as i showed earlier we have
kibana which is a ui system that
basically provides a ui layer and gives
you access to do a lot of this
capability directly in a ui but we'll be
thinking about the interface a bit more
in a moment because we're talking about
clients at the end of this session
just to give you a few numbers um
there's now over 400 api endpoints in
elasticsearch pretty much any of the
things that you can do with
elasticsearch can be done through http
and we expose apis for doing it so even
things like the ml capabilities for
defining the jobs that can run
for starting and stopping those ml jobs
all of that can be done through the api
configuration of the cluster
pretty much anything
which means there's a lot of data
structures and there's a lot of types
that are involved in that so we have
over 50 distinct querying types um over
70 different types of aggregations so
how do you want to group data and and
analyze information in aggregate form
and and those different field types i
talked about for defining fields
explicitly that map to your data types
that you're sending in so there's a lot
of a lot of parts of this api
and keep that in mind when i come to
talking about the.net client in a moment
so i work on the language clients team
there's about eight or nine of us and we
maintain the language clients
um these are the the main ones there are
others sort of subsets of these but
these are the main ones and all of the
sort of core languages are covered there
and each client is designed to be
idiomatic to the language so java.net
they're the most strongly typed clients
we provide classes that represent
requests and responses so that you can
work with your data in a pattern that
you're used to in other.net applications
for example but for the other languages
you know those are designed more in mind
with whichever
sort of patterns are used and design
patterns are needed for those languages
um and so you should find them sort of
pretty compatible if you're working with
any of those languages to things you've
seen elsewhere in them
so in terms of existing clients
the existing.net client today
is built of kind of two
nuget packages
and this is in the 7x range so 717 is
kind of the latest minor version of that
um and this is the client that's out
there today and is publicly available
you use it against the 17 uh 717 server
or 7x server
but you can also use it against ato and
that's quite important at the moment
because we haven't gade an ato client
just yet um but we do have now an ato a
kind of compatibility header that you
can send across that tells it what type
of
version of response you want so now the
717 client can be used against the nato
server as long as you enable that header
so that
the server knows to send you data in a
particular format
and this client is built with two parts
the elasticsearch.net library is our
low-level client
and for probably 99 of people you
shouldn't be using this you don't need
to be using this directly
it is a very low level sort of
abstraction over the top of essentially
the transport functionality of talking
to elasticsearch
and
basic mappings between
an endpoint name and a url really
and what this is is it's our kind of
dependency free layer that's fairly
unopinionated about sort of working as a
client and it really is focused on
handling the transport functionality so
when you configure your client you can
give it urls for all of the nodes that
are available in your system and it can
keep track of those it will round robin
requests to those and it will also
identify if a node becomes unresponsive
it will stop trying to send it requests
for a period of time that kind of
transport layout functionality
is inc sort of capitulated in there and
it does have a basic form of request and
response but if you're going to be using
it you need to pass it the actual json
structures to send to the server and
that you're going to get back so that's
usually either in byte or string form
so that's why it's not really most
useful for most people it's more of a
building block library
and potentially a scenario if you're in
extremely high performance scenarios and
you want a bit more control over
allocations around json
to type mappings you might start using
it for that but generally what you want
to be using is nest
nest is the high level client
and this is where the strongly typed
nature of the client starts to come in
so we have mappings
and types that represent all of the
requests and responses for all of the
endpoints plus all of the subtypes of
those that they then expose as well and
as i talked about that's over 400
endpoints so that's already sort of 800
types just for requests and responses
before you start getting into all those
nuanced data structures all of the
different representations of an
aggregation of the different fields that
can be configured and things like that
we also expose a query dsl
representation so elasticsearch has a
querying domain specific language that
you use and we've modeled that as
closely as we can to sort of how you
would like to work with this dsl through
net
it's not necessarily perfect but we
provide two patterns for for all of the
types in.net uh for the high-level
clients so we have the object
initializer pattern which is really you
know create a new search request and set
properties and then pass it to the
client and that might work quite nicely
in some scenarios but as things get more
complex and you build up these kind of
deeper and deeper queries all of this
nested new object creation gets a little
bit painful and so in that scenario we
also provide what we call the fluent
syntax which gives you kind of this
chain ability of method calls that you
can make to configure those components
and we'll see what that looks like when
i get to the code in a moment but these
are the two projects today they're you
know extremely highly used
as i say nest is the one that you want
to be picking up if you're kind of
getting into this stuff brand new
so there are some problems with the
existing client uh we've kind of
identified that we we're starting to try
and work on solutions for
the first thing is it's handwritten um
nearly all of it's hand written and what
i mean by this is we have some basic
code generation for the low-level client
that will be able to say given this the
specification that exists in
elasticsearch the repo we can kind of
create the endpoint to url mappings and
the basic query string structures that a
request and response to that endpoint
might take
but all we can do after that is
basically stub out the request and
response types as partial classes and
then the maintainers myself come in and
we fill in the blanks and put in all of
the properties that are available on
those request response and have to model
everything
and in the early days of elasticsearch
when there were tens or hundreds of
endpoints this wasn't too much of a
problem but obviously that's a lot of
maintenance work as you start getting
towards 400 endpoints that can all be
evolving in each
minor release of elasticsearch and so
that does mean that at times the api
that's available in.net isn't always 100
consistent with the api of elasticsearch
so we might not have properties exposed
on those requests and responses that you
can set and send in the data over the
wire
this is obviously a problem if you find
one raise an issue and we'll get that in
as soon as we can but it's a manual
piece of work and there is obviously
gaps in terms of understanding what's
exactly been done by the server team to
make sure it's in all of the clients the
other thing about this existing client
is we have an internalized version of
something called utf-8 json which we use
for serialization and utf-8 json is a
kind of open source high level uh high
performance i should say serializer
that's generally about trying to be
quite low allocation and quite efficient
but it's quite an old open source
project that's kind of gone out of
maintenance so our copy actually lives
inside our own code base we actually
internalized that code
mainly because we needed some
customizations to the to it that were
very sort of elastic search type
specific because we have a lot of
polymorphic types in in the requests and
responses particularly around
aggregations and searching that are
really hard to map and you generally
need some quite low level ability to
write json code to be able to model
those
and serialize to and from them so that's
the reason we've got it kind of
internalized and we've patched bits of
it over time as we've found bugs with it
it generally performs pretty well and
it's probably better than using
something like newtonsoft json in terms
of allocations and memory footprint
but it has some issues it's not perfect
and we've definitely found areas where
it over allocates and it doesn't
necessarily return memory as quickly as
it should do
there's a lot of maintenance in that
code if we're going to carry it forward
and there's 10 years nearly of
historical decisions that have gone into
this library it came out very early when
elasticsearch was first available and
it's evolved
over time as elasticsearch has grown and
so it means the early decisions that
were made around the structure of how
some of this works were designed at the
kind of tens or hundreds of apis that we
need to model uh kind of era and now
we're at this point where we have
hundreds of complex types that we have
to deal with and also
nets evolved as a language the sort of
patterns and the language features and
capabilities have changed in 10 years
we've gone through the net core era as
well um and so it would be nice if we
could start to take a little bit more
advantage of that as where we can so
these are some of the problems that when
i joined about a year and a half ago i
kind of identified as things that maybe
i'd like to look at and the team had
already got some of these in mind as
well as things that are problematic
and so i can introduce what we're
working on at the moment in terms of the
ato climb which is the new the new
elasticsearch.net package
so there's a few cool things uh it's a
new name
doesn't we don't call it nest anymore
partly because i couldn't really work
out if nest meant anything to anyone
that was outside of using it today it's
not something you would first think to
search for if you're a brand new user to
elasticsearch
and you go okay well i'm doing.net i'm
doing elasticsearch i need the client
you're probably not going to think to
search the word nest um but that's not
the main reason we've made this change i
also wanted to give it a new package an
assembly name because of
some of the stuff that we're doing that
means it is going to be a fairly big
break um historically i've experienced
the breaking nature of elasticsearch
between major versions and gone through
some of the pain that you have to do to
upgrade between those and it is a bit of
a trade-off between how do we evolve
something while not breaking while
making things better
but in this case we've made some
decisions that really kind of forced our
hand and i'll talk a bit more about
those
now so the first important thing is
we know that it's not sustainable to
keep manually creating the types for
the the client ourselves
you know it leads to those gaps it leads
to errors
and it's time consuming it means that my
time on the client is not spent making
it more
performant or adding sort of value add
higher level features that make it
easier to do particular things within
elasticsearch it's mostly spent
maintaining that api surface and just
keeping
those roughly consistent and so we're
moving to a code generation approach for
our new version of clients and as a
client's team what we've done is built
out a typescript representation of the
the types of the that can represent
those api endpoints and the requests and
responses and all the subtypes of those
and model them in such a way that we can
also add our own various attributes to
those that we know are kind of elastic
searchisms that we need to deal with
like these kind of polymorphic types
where we have various different forms of
polymorphism and how that's modeled in
the data structures that come back and
so we need to flag those so that
individual clients can do the best thing
when they're co-generating to produce
kind of the most useful code for that
language and so we start with the
typescript we then use a compilation
process that eventually will after
checking a bunch of things spit out a
json schema it's a custom schema and
some of you may be thinking
why not use something like open api we
are looking at what we can do to
actually generate an open api spec
but
open api doesn't expose quite enough of
the kind of
distinct possibilities around that
polymorphism that i talked about around
these different response types
so it makes it very hard to model it
fully um and so that's not sufficient
for actually co-generating a full client
at this point in time and so what we've
done is we've created this sort of
custom schema that gives us the
capability to add all of those
additional flags and that additional
sort of meta information into the spec
that we can then as client team consume
so now i'm doing that code generation
what we do is we take the json schema
i'd read that in i do a bunch of sort of
upfront work working out what types that
needs how those things interrelate and
you know essentially create sort of a
meta structure that represents what the
client should look like and then i'm
using the roslin apis of.net to actually
produce
the new client code
that's a talk in itself and probably you
know maybe next year i can come back and
talk about a bit more how that actually
works but fundamentally we build up you
know using the roslin apis you can build
up a syntax tree that's essentially what
the compiler sees when it looks at your
code in in its written form but we can
build that syntax tree up by hand in
code uh from the spec and then i can use
it to spit out c sharp files at the end
of it that represent those types so all
of the requests and responses um all of
the sort of related types that those
then depend on are now co-generated off
of this spec
and i think at the moment when i run the
code generator at least two and a half
thousand types are being created now
automatically off of this spec that's
obviously a lot of work to get a code
generator of that scale working
accurately and i'm still working through
some of the final issues which is why we
don't have a gi client just yet but i
think we can see the benefits that means
you get much greater consistency we'll
be able to run this process you know
every day if we want to in our in our
build systems uh against the spec and if
things have changed the client will be
updated to reflect them and you'll
essentially get day one sort of parity
between client and server which will be
really nice and it also as i say freeze
my time up to do that value ad work and
and deal with those sort of high level
challenges that people face when
building applications against
elasticsearch
one of the other key changes is we move
to system text json for the
serialization so if you haven't heard of
it this is microsoft's
new in the box json serializer um it's
been in the box with dot net for a few
releases now but it first came out it
was a little bit kind of feature
incomplete in terms of what we needed
but we're now at the point where it does
enough it doesn't do everything i'd like
but it does enough that i can kind of
work around those gaps that we can
actually use it internally as a
serializer
and what that means is
we no longer have to maintain all of
this serialization code ourselves we can
rely on microsoft we've done a really
good job of creating a library profiling
it and have got the engineering
power behind that to actually make sure
that we have a really good high level uh
hype
efficiency serializer within.net that
ships in the box so it's not a
dependency you necessarily need to take
because newer.net versions just have it
available to them as well but it is
netstandard compatible so if you're
still using the libraries on sort of.net
framework you can still use that
serializer in our newer packages
but this gives us
a lot of work to do this as it turns out
there's a lot of custom conversion that
needs to happen as i say for that that
polymorphic nature of some of our types
and our more complex json structures
but we're at a point now where that's
pretty much working for all of the key
parts of the client
the other thing we did was we removed
what is essentially the low-level client
and made it its own package called
elastic.transport
um this would be the thing that you you
know if you're in a really high
performance scenario and you're building
more of a
library on top you might be looking at
and this is really just about that
transport layer nature but we've tried
to make it a little bit more sort of
product agnostic so it's a generic
transport that works for our distributed
setup that we could apply to other of
our products and hint we might be able
to do clients that are built on this for
some of our other services so you can
manage those
for example enterprise search has an api
it would be nice to have a net client
for that
and ultimately this gives us with all of
this meaningless
breaking changes as a nature of the fact
that we've gone from something that was
handcrafted with care and we ensured
every type name was unique and didn't
conflict with other types within the in
the name space we're now in a situation
where we're generating more generally
off of the specs so
we have to have some more name spaces in
there type names may change because
we're going off the spec we don't want
to make this sort of go back to the
point where we've gone off a spec and
then we handcraft everything by using
configuration and so we've accepted that
there will be some breaks but most of
the stuff is reasonably consistent
and i'm trying to close those gaps as
best i can but also this means we have
the opportunity to try and remove some
legacy and and make the client better
take some feedback that people have
given us over the sort of past few years
about what they don't do and don't like
about how it's kind of structured
and try and take that on board as well
so with that i can get to a little bit
of a demo i'm going to be relying on the
wi-fi so hopefully elastic cloud's up
and running
just in case it's not let's start a
docket container behind the scenes
so
what i'm going to do for this demo is it
is you know again it's going to be a
getting started demo i'm going to use
the new ato client
i'm using a ci build of the new client
because i added some stuff last week i
wanted to to include in here so um it's
been a good experience for me to kind of
dog food my own client and find a few of
the gaps
but it's pretty much um
got everything that i wanted so
in terms of the data we're dealing with
hopefully this is big enough at the back
um this is just the csv file that we're
going to be working with which is
some 600 000 rows of stock data from
2013 to 2018 i think
and you can see you know we have for
each day
there's uh for each stock symbol that
was on the market there's the high low
close
values for those
um so that's what we're working with in
terms of
the net modeling of that then i have
essentially a poco dto that just models
the the fields that are available there
the only additional stuff in this file
is a little bit of a factory method just
to parse it out of the file and create
the type and i've got a very basic
dictionary for just some of the the
stock symbol names to look them up
against their full name that will be
useful for for searching in a moment
so the first thing i'm going to need to
do
is hopefully
i'm still on elastic cloud i am so this
is my elastic cloud deployment that i've
spun up um these credentials will be
gone by the end of the talk so hopefully
no one will hack them in the meantime
but what i've grabbed from the cloud is
the cloud id this is just a really long
uh sort of string it's base encoded data
that we need to connect and this is the
easiest way to get started with the
client
you don't need to kind of get all of the
urls and things just chuck in the cloud
id and we'll parse that data from this
string the only other thing i need is
going to be the username and password
and elastic cloud gives us a username
password by default when it started and
i'm just going to grab that password for
the elastic user
this commented code here is about
setting up a local
version of the client that talks to my
local docker instance we don't need it
if the cloud
is reachable from here
but you can see the setup is
very similar just with some additional
information but for the cloud all i need
to do is call new elasticsearch client
pass in that cloud id and basically a
basic auth
object here you can also use api key
authentication if you need to
so that's what we need to do to create
an instance of the client
and the first thing i'm going to do in
this code here
is call into the client and i'm going to
call into the indices area of the client
that relates to apis under the kind of
indexing namespace uh or sort of the sub
area of the api i should say
so indices exists async just calls into
a method that's going to map to the
exists endpoint for that index area
and it just takes in this scenario the
minimum i need is this index name which
is just a string that represents the
name of the index that i'm going to
check for so this will check if the
index exists
what this code will then do is say well
if it doesn't exist i'm going to create
it
and so in here again we're in that sort
of indices area but now we're calling
create async we're passing the index
name and then this is
nearly completely fluent there's a
little bit of it isn't fluent here um
and i'll show you the uh the 7x version
in a minute but this is sort of this
syntax down here is kind of what i mean
by fluent so we call into dot settings
and within settings we can set number of
shards one number of replicas zero
and and basically configure it this
isn't a production ready uh demo so
don't follow these settings for your own
production systems the other thing we
can provide is these mappings so this is
how we define that explicit mapping
between fields that we're going to be
sending elasticsearch and how they
should be stored now this is where i'm
not influencing text because at the
moment my code generator doesn't know
how to generate the fluent descriptor
for this
but sometime next week it should but for
now what i'm doing is just newing up the
the mappings just to show you what this
looks like in 7x it's not all that
dissimilar but with the fluent syntax
you call into doc keyword and then you
can access the name that you want to set
as a keyword field in here and what this
does is take the the name but rather
than you hard coding magic strings
everywhere that represent the the name
you want to
mark as a keyword field we can do what
we call type inference and here you just
provide an expression that says okay
well i want the the symbol property on
the stock data to be used as the field
name and what we do behind the scenes by
default that's essentially just going to
camel case the property name
because that's the default expectation
for the json structures you'd like to
send in but you can configure that and
change how that inference works if you
need to
the other thing we're doing then is
setting up these number properties and
again it's this fluent syntax dot number
once you're into there you can figure
its name and the specific number type
that you want
so back to version eight uh the
difference here is that as i say i'm
just creating this kind of dictionary
myself with the field name without
inference here and the the type of
property i want that field to be
so the reason i'm doing this explicit
mapping is for the symbols for example
the msft or something that would
represent microsoft stock we're not
going to need to full text search that
field because generally we're just going
to say we'll find me all of the msft
stock
it's not going to be a full text type of
search and so rather than have
elasticsearch index that into an
inverted index that supports the
capability of full text search which
requires memory and data structures
we're just going to say actually now we
know how this this type of data is only
ever going to be queried in a full text
form sorry an exact match form
so we will define it purely as a keyword
rather than as a text property
these other ones are a little bit more
interesting so these are the numeric
data that represents the stock values
i've explicitly marked these as floats
because although elasticsearch will
generally infer that quite happily
if there's kind of decimal places in the
data i do know that my data file
if the numbers are
rounded to 0.0 it just gives an exact
integer looking value so if the first
document that goes in actually has that
sort of integer representation of the
numbers elasticsearch will see that and
go well this looks like an integer i
will treat this field as an integer
field um when actually the vast majority
of these documents are going to need to
have the decimal places so this is where
you get into explicit mapping you
understand your data so that you can
give elastic search and proper guidance
about how it should treat it
so in this case i'm just saying they're
all floats
after this runs i'm going to check that
my response was valid and whether it was
acknowledged by the server and if it
wasn't i'll throw an exception and then
i need to get some data into
elasticsearch so we can index data
document by document just doing an index
document
command
and that's fine for sort of ad hoc small
amounts of data as they're coming in
but it's not super efficient if we're
doing this kind of scenario where we
want to ingest a large volume of data
rapidly because each of those index
document requests is going to be an
individual http request so there's
overhead and
sort of back and forth with the server
for that to happen so elasticsearch
supports a bulk api endpoint that takes
a new line delimited json format that
represents various operations you want
to perform and we provide what we call a
helper that kind of wraps that api for
doing bulk ingestion so in this case we
we call that bulk all and what this
takes is an innumerable of data so if i
jump down here this is just an
innumerable uh on my type down here
that's essentially reading line by line
from the file and yielding those lines
as it gets them
so just a sort of poor man's innumerable
there but any innumerable source can be
passed in here and then the other
configuration which again is in this
fluent syntax defines how do we want
that data treated so i'm going to send
it to the index with this index name i
want to deal with back off scenarios so
if the server says whoa i'm overloaded
it will give us a 429 or something back
to say can you back off for a bit i
haven't got the capacity to take any
more data right now
we tell the client well okay in this
case we'll retry up to 20 times in that
scenario and each time we'll wait 10
seconds and give the server that that
time
to back off
the other scenario we're dealing with
here is what do we do if documents are
dropped so although the request may
succeed and elasticsearch receives our 1
000 documents or whatever we're sending
it um if some of those have data that
doesn't can't be applied to the mappings
that exist for those types then
elasticsearch is going to throw up its
hands and say this isn't valid i can't i
can't store this
and so those will be dropped
and by default we want to deal with
those but we want to deal with them
separately so we're going to say
continue after any drop documents ignore
the fact that you know maybe one out of
the set that we sent couldn't be indexed
but we will this callback will be called
for us that we can provide some handling
for that so we might here i'm logging
into a console but you could also put
these into a dead letter queue or some
other structure and deal with them as
you need to the final things i'm setting
are
parallelism you don't have to define
this manually i have here just to show
that it exists we'll infer a cpu count
by default um but this is how many
concurrent http requests are we're going
to be sending as part of this batch work
that we're doing and then the size is
how many documents do we put into each
individual request essentially so here
we're saying a batch size of a thousand
so we put a thousand documents into that
uh request body and ship it up to the
server finding the exact balance that's
the most efficient is again a bit of
trial and error it depends on your data
structures and how large things are
you know you could assume oh i'm going
to make this 10 000 and everything will
be quicker but obviously you're then
getting to larger and larger request
sizes that have to be shipped over the
network and it might actually be less
efficient to put that a large volume of
data per request so finding the right
trade-off for your network environment
and for the data you're sending is is
important but somewhere in a thousand is
a good starting point and then you can
kind of play around with the figures
now this bulk hall is in our observable
and it actually kicks off the operation
in the background on a background thread
and then that's actually started
immediately but in this case what we
want to do is actually block this
application proceeding until we know
that that's all finished so i'm going to
use this observer here that's a helper
again on top of that observable and this
observer just says well actually i want
to wait on this thing completing
in this case i'm going to wait for up to
10 minutes for this complete operation
to run and every time we get a this is
the on next delegate so every time a
response comes back uh to this this bulk
operation that's happening behind the
scenes we want to run this delegate and
in this case we'll just log to the
console so before i get on to the rest
of this code let's kick this off and
pray that the network's good
and we should start to see some data
uh being indexed there hopefully
yes good
um it's a bit small but all it's saying
is data indexed and that's just each of
those bulk operations um happening and
going over the wire to the server so the
600 000 records it's going to take it
you know a few seconds to complete but
with this bulk operation this bulk all
helper i should say um you can see we've
just indexed nearly half a million over
half a million documents uh while we've
been stood here uh listening to them
chat on
and so that's actually now in a position
where we've got our data in and
the next thing we might want to do once
we've got data in into our index is
actually start searching on it so let's
start with a really simple search uh
let's say we just want to get back all
of the documents for the microsoft stock
but what we're going to do is we're
going to create a query as part of our
search here and the simplest query for
this scenario where we just want to say
does it match this
cons does this match on this term or not
and just filter the documents down is to
use a filter query in here
which is turn based so the field again
using inference would be whatever is the
symbol
property on our stock object or stock
data type will be used as a field name
and then the value we want to match is
msft so this is keyword match remember
so it's case sensitive it's an exact
match because that's how we map the data
and then we're going to limit the
response size here so we only just want
the first 20 for now and we can do a
sort
in on the server to get them descending
by date
once we
get back a response we can access the
documents on that response and because
this search async here is strongly typed
using this generic to our data type
these documents will be deserialized off
the response into our stock data type
for us so once we're here data is a
stock data object instance and so that
means we can just access its properties
and write some stuff out to the console
so not too exciting but we can just run
that
and again we've hit the break point so
we've got our first 20 rows there
with the values for each of those dates
so
that's a very simple kind of
filter-based query
um
that we can do
if we want to do something that is a bit
more realistic with some full text
search
let's run this search here um
the index again is the same index the
query now is going to be a match so this
is where we start to get into full text
searching and what we're saying is we
want to match this term inc within the
name of the stock data so for the name
of the company
again we're just going to get the first
20 in descending and again we can access
the documents so the difference here is
that we're now starting to go into that
full text index and say find any of the
documents that have the term inc in
there somewhere as a distinct token word
we run the search
and as we'd expect we get the data the
interesting thing to point out although
this is a bit small let's just make this
a bit
bigger um
the uh the name here so this one is
obviously uppercase i and then nc this
one has a period after it so because of
the the tokenization and the analysis of
that that string field as it went into
the index um it means we've matched all
of these documents which is typically
the behavior you're going to want for
this kind of stuff but again you can
configure these options for your needs
as i'm getting towards the end of time
i'll quickly show the aggregation
example and then we are
good for any questions that we may have
um so in this case again the search is
what we started with the first time so
we're going to just do a simple filter
for all of the microsoft uh stock data
but now we're getting into a scenario
where we actually want to do some sort
of aggregation of that data and
understand in a different form and so in
this case what we're going to do is say
well let's try and get all of the
microsoft data and and for each month
work out the total volume of trades that
happened
so in this scenario what we can do is we
can use a date histogram aggregation
which is essentially bucket the data by
some calendar interval
in this case the calendar interval is
monthly
when we create the aggregation that we
want we provide a name this allows us to
grab it back off the response later on
in terms of the field we're using again
we're using the kind of inferred field
name for the date property on our data
type because that's obviously the only
date we have to actually uh bucket this
on
we can order it by key descending which
essentially is date descending and then
we can actually perform a
sub-aggregation so we said we wanted
everything by month which we've achieved
by doing a date histogram aggregation
now we're in the situation where we want
to total up
or sum the volume of trades that
occurred so in this case we do another
aggregation
under each sort of date bucket and this
is a sum aggregation called trade
volumes that again just needs to know uh
the field that we want to sum up in this
case the volume field
and so when this comes back we get this
aggregations on the response here
and what we can do is call into the
these methods to start accessing
aggregations from there so uh we can
call getdate histogram we would want the
date histogram aggregation named by
month and then we want to access each
individual bucket that's on there which
is just a collection of those buckets by
month
and then we can just four each over
these in a standard for each loop here
and for each monthly bucket we'll call
getsum which allows us to then go into
its sub-aggregations and ask for the sum
aggregation called trade volumes and
this is just a basic metric aggregation
so in this case we don't have buckets we
just have the value which is the result
of the sum operation and so now we have
the volume for the number of trades that
occurred
and
in this case what we're doing then is
writing these out to the console uh and
we can access the key to get essentially
the date of the bucket so we can put the
date in and it scrolls off here and then
we're just writing out that volume
so if i now run this example
you can see we get all of the
dates bucketed so 2018 backwards from
the age of this data and this is the the
number of trades that occurred for
microsoft stock in that given month so
there's you know a few scenarios there
basic sort of uh exact matching of data
the more common full text searching that
you might do against you know larger
volumes of text data and then this
capability to do sort of metrics and
data analysis with aggregations and
things like that
so we're pretty much at the end of time
let's just run this
final couple of slides
um
so in terms of resources for what i've
shown you again the most important link
is this bitly link so if you grab a
photo of this slide and grab that link
this will take you to the slide deck and
then you've got all the other links i'm
about to show you um obviously the first
thing is our github repo for the net
client so if you're working with the.net
client and you have issues or ideas or
whatever
you can you can write those and report
them to us in in this repo
we have our documentation um on
elastic.cos so we have obviously guides
for elasticsearch itself and then we
have the client-specific guides that you
may need to find
the existing 7x client nest is on nougat
under the name nest which is easily
searchable and if you want to start
playing with the new client it's in
alpha 10 at the moment
elastic.client.elasticsearch is is now
how we're referring to that package name
and that's going to be the the new
client going forward so if you're really
interested in seeing how that works in
your scenarios with the early alphas
just don't put it in production yet
because we will have some more changes
then you can go and find it there
the example i've just shown you is in my
repo so
elasticsearch.examples and you'll find
what i've just shown you on screen if
you want to look at those queries again
i'll just dig into the code a little bit
more
and we have a online forum discuss
elastic dot co if you have general
questions you know
that could be not just client related
but search related as well how do i do x
what's the best way to get started with
you know why and why i'm running into
these things so that's about questions
the repo is more about issues and direct
features that you need
otherwise
thank you very much for coming i'm glad
to see some people here uh if you don't
get to talk to me after the session and
i do ask that you come up to find me
during the next few days if you have
questions or feedback on elasticsearch
and net but if not you can find me
online at steve j gordon and i've been
asked to remind you to to leave your
review as you leave um on the way out so
thank you very much appreciate your time
and i'll see you hopefully next year